This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. A man walks down a dark alley. He's dressed all in black. Black beanie hat, black gloves. He approaches a door, drops to one knee, and produces from his pocket a small metal tool. He inserts the tool into the keyhole. He deftly slides the tool around inside the keyhole until he's in. Security has been breached. But only in the movies, because prospective lock pickers take note, you generally can't do that with just a pick, or hairpin, or a paperclip. There are two tools you need to pick a lock. And one of them is usually left out.
这里是99%隐形。我是罗曼·马尔斯。一个男人走在黑漆漆的巷子里。他全身穿戴着黑色的衣服。黑色的毛线帽，黑色的手套。他走近一扇门，单膝跪地，从口袋里掏出一个小型金属工具。他把工具插进钥匙孔。他熟练地在钥匙孔里滑动工具，直到进去了。安全被攻破了。但只发生在电影里，因为想要学开锁的人请注意，通常你只用一把锁匠工具、发夹或回形针是做不到这一点的。开锁需要两个工具。而且其中一个通常被忽略了。
When you see people picking locks in movies, this is the part they always forget. The tension wrench. This is a tension wrench. It's a L-shaped piece of metal with a little twist in it. An L-shaped piece of metal that, with one hand, you insert at the bottom of the keyhole, while the other hand uses the pick to work the pins in the lock. And hold the lock with a little bit of rotational tension. That, by the way, is Lee Honeywell, showing our producer Sam Greenspan how to pick a lock. Lee is a digital security expert and amateur lockpicking instructor. I taught a bunch of people how to pick locks at a feminist science fiction convention one year.
当你在电影里看到人们开锁时，这就是他们总是忘掉的那部分。张力扳手。这是一个张力扳手。它是一块带有一点扭曲的L形金属。一块L形的金属，你用一只手把它插在钥匙孔的底部，同时另一手用开锁器去拨动锁里的销子。并用一点旋转张力握住锁。顺便说一下，那是李·亨尼韦尔，在向我们的制作人萨姆·格林斯潘展示如何开锁。李是一位数字安全专家和业余开锁教练。我曾经有一年在一次科幻小说大会上教过一群人如何开锁。
I'm at Lee at our office in San Francisco. We sat in a conference room among piles of tension wrenches and lock picks and special practice locks, built for the picking. You have to push each pin up far enough that you can't see that bottom part, see how you can see the bottom part there. There's two pieces of the pin, you have to get.
我和李在我们在旧金山的办公室。我们坐在一间会议室里，周围是一堆张力扳手、开锁器和专为开锁而制造的特殊练习锁。你必须把每个销子往上推得足够高，让你看不到底部的那部分，看你怎么能看到那底部的部分。销子有两部分，你必须把它弄好。
So when you pick a lock, you're using the pick and tension wrench to do the work of the key. You need them both. It's okay, so I'm kinda pretty good with pick into the keyhole. Oh, is that it? I did it. Yay!
所以当你开锁时，你是在用开锁器和张力扳手来做钥匙的工作。你两个都需要。好吧，所以我把开锁器弄进钥匙孔里还算挺熟练的。哦，就是这样吗？我成功了。耶！
Yay! The pursuit of lock picking is as old as the lock, which is itself as old as civilization. But in the entire history of the world, there was only one brief moment about 70 years, where you could put something under lock and key, a chest to save your home, and have complete, unwavering certainty that no intruder could get to it. A feeling that security experts call perfect security. And since we lost perfect security in the 1850s, it has remained elusive. Despite tremendous leaps forward in security technology,
耶！对开锁的追求和锁一样古老，而锁本身和文明一样古老。但在世界的整个历史中，只有过一个短暂的时刻，大约70年，你可以把某样东西放在锁和钥匙下，一个用来保护你家的箱子，并且拥有完全的、毫不动摇的确定性，即没有任何入侵者能接近它。安全专家称这种感觉为绝对安全。自从我们在19世纪50年代失去绝对安全以来，它就一直难以捉摸。尽管安全技术取得了巨大的飞跃，
we have never been able to get perfect security back. Locks go back at least as far as ancient Egypt. But in March, I'm dropping a big paper, theorizing that the Mesopotamians were actually the creators of the original lock and that the Egyptians then learned it from them. This is Skylar Town. I am Skylar Town and I am a security anthropologist,
我们再也没能找回绝对安全。锁的历史至少可以追溯到古埃及。但在三月，我将发表一篇重要论文，推测美索不达米亚人实际上是原始锁的创造者，然后埃及人向他们学习了这一点。这是斯凯勒·托恩。我是斯凯勒·托恩，我是一名安全人类学家，
research scholar with the Ronan Institute, but generally just an independent academic of all things related to locks. For the Middle Ages on, four hundreds of years, locks were not very good. If you were poor, you could have a terrible lock, and if you had some money, you could have a terrible lock with some added features that might, at best, confuse a trespasser. They're chest with false keyholes, they're padlocks even with false keyholes.
罗南研究所的研究学者，但总的来说是一个研究与锁相关的一切事物的独立学者。从中古时期开始，几百年间，锁都不是很好。如果你很穷，你可能会有一个很烂的锁，如果你有点钱，你可能会有一个带有附加功能的很烂的锁，充其量可能会迷惑闯入者。它们是带有假钥匙孔的箱子，甚至是带有假钥匙孔挂锁。
False keyholes, which they hoped would draw the thief away from the true keyhole. Some locks had false keyholes that even had lock-like components affixed to them, so it felt like they were attached to the latching mechanism, but actually weren't. Seriously, the best you could do was try to confuse an intruder into picking a fake lock. But as soon as the real keyhole was known, the security was pretty much nil. There was no perfect security, there was no lock that could keep everyone out. And then in the 1770s, an English guy named Joseph Brahma entered the locksmithing scene. And this is like a wizard from the future had come back in time and invented the most
假钥匙孔，他们希望这能把小偷从真正的钥匙孔引开。有些锁的假钥匙孔甚至附带了类似锁的组件，所以感觉它们连接到了闭锁机构上，但实际上并没有。说真的，你能做的最好的事情就是试图迷惑入侵者去开一把假锁。但一旦真正的钥匙孔暴露，安全性基本上就等于零。没有绝对安全，没有哪把锁能把所有人挡在外面。然后在18世纪70年代，一个名叫约瑟夫·布拉马的英国人进入了锁匠界。这就好像一个来自未来的巫师回到过去，发明了最
amazing lock in the world. If the name Joseph Brahma sounds familiar to you fellow engineering history nerds, this is the same Joseph Brahma who invented the flush toilet and the first water pumping fire engine and a Numatic tree murdering machine that it would literally just rip a full-ground tree out of the ground by its roots That one wasn't as popular, but it was pretty cool and so Joseph Brahma inventor time wizard tree murderer He was really interested in locks. He made something called, aptly, the Brahma safety lock.
世界上惊人的锁。如果约瑟夫·布拉马这个名字听起来对你们这些工程历史书呆子很熟悉，这就是那个发明了抽水马桶、第一台抽水消防气泵以及一台气动砍树机的同一个约瑟夫·布拉马，它字面意思就是能把一棵大树从根部连根拔起。那个不是很受欢迎，但它相当酷，所以约瑟夫·布拉马发明家、时间巫师、砍树杀手他对锁真的很感兴趣。他制作了一种恰如其分地被称为布拉马安全锁的东西。
Brahma disconnected the key from the both. So what the key is doing is it's rotating and inner chamber of this lock. Take my word for it, explaining how this thing works does not make for compelling radio. But the main thing about this lock is that it added levels of complexity in between the key and the bolt.
布拉马把钥匙和锁栓断开了。所以钥匙所做的是旋转这个锁的内部腔室。相信我，解释这东西是怎么运作的并不能做成引人注目的广播。但这个锁的主要特点是，它在钥匙和锁栓之间增加了复杂性。
It's like a whole roob Goldberg scenario plays out inside the lock. The key touches one thing, which moves another thing and triggers it. And Brahma was so confident in his lock that he actually published a pamphlet detailing exactly how it worked. No more hiding the keyhole or shrouding the locks operation in secrecy. Brahma revealed everything about the lock and still claimed that it could not be opened
这就像一个鲁布·戈德堡式的场景在锁内部上演。钥匙触碰了一个东西，这移动了另一个东西并触发了它。布拉马对他的锁非常自信，以至于他实际上发表了一份小册子，详细说明了它是如何运作的。不再隐藏钥匙孔或将锁的操作笼罩在神秘之中。布拉马揭示了关于锁的一切，并声称它仍然无法被打开
without the key. And he also had another idea that would revolutionize locksmithing. He also contributes the idea of turning this whole thing into a contest, showmanship. So as soon as he has a padlock version of this lock that he is very confident in, he puts it in the window of his stored Picadilly and he paints on it a message a challenge in gold lettering quote
没有钥匙。他还有另一个将彻底革新锁匠业的想法。他还贡献了把整件事变成一场比赛、一场作秀的想法。因此，一旦他有了一个他非常有信心的这款锁的挂锁版本，他就把它放在他位于皮卡迪利大街的商店的橱窗里，并在上面用金字塔涂上了一条信息、一个挑战，引述道
The artist who can make an instrument that will pick or open this lock shall receive 200 guineas the moment it is produced 200 guineas in 1777 is something north of 20,000 British pounds today. And people try, people actually take a real honest shot at this, but no one, not even with their own tools, could hack it. And it remained in that window for 70 plus years, challenging all comers and everybody failed to open it. Brahms knew unbeatable lock and the hoopla surrounding it caught the attention of the British crown and they wanted to up the game.
能够制造出能撬开或打开这把锁的仪器的艺术家，一经生产将获得200几尼奖励。1777年的200几尼相当于今天的两万多英镑。人们尝试了，人们真的做出了诚实的尝试，但没有人，即使使用他们自己的工具，也能破解它。它在那个橱窗里呆了70多年，挑战着所有的挑战者，每个人都未能打开它。布拉马知道无法被击败的锁以及围绕它的喧嚣引起了英国皇室的注意，他们想把赌注提高。
They wanted a lock that wouldn't just be unbreakable but would also alert the owner if someone tried to get into it. The government sponsored a contest with 100 British pounds as reward. The best one at the time was Jeremiah Chubb's detector lock. And the way that this worked is that when you lifted one of the tumblers up too high, it would actually trip a latching mechanism that would hold that tumbler up in the air too high and it wouldn't drop back down again.
他们想要一把不仅牢不可破，而且如果有人试图进入还能警告主人的锁。政府赞助了一场比赛，奖金为100英镑。当时最好的是杰里迈亚·查ub的探测锁。其运作方式是，当你把其中一个制动片抬得太高时，它实际上会触发一个闭锁机构，将那个制动片保持在太高的空中，并且不会再掉下来。
And when that happened, the lock would completely freeze up, even the key would open it. Until you put a different key and rotate it in the opposite direction and reset all of the tumblers. And so if you went to unlock a chest or a vault or your front door and the key to your chub detector lock didn't work, you would know that someone had tried to get into it and that they had failed. Advertisements for the detector lock ran in the Bleak House cereals, which read, quote, my name is Chubb, that makes the patent locks. Look upon my works, ye burclers, in despair. And as these newer and better locks were getting invented, the public spectacle around them rose to a fever pitch.
当这种情况发生时，锁会完全冻结，连钥匙也打不开它。直到你放入一把不同的钥匙并朝相反方向旋转它，重置所有的制动片。所以如果你去打开一个箱子、一个金库或你的前门，而你的查勃探测锁的钥匙不管用了，你就会知道有人试图进去过，而且他们失败了。探测锁的广告刊登在《荒凉山庄》连载中，上面写着，引述，我的名子叫查勃，制造专利锁。看看我的作品，你们这些窃贼，感到绝望吧。随着这些更新更好的锁的发明，围绕它们的公众奇观达到了狂热的程度。
At one point, they offered a guy in prison parole if he could break the chop lock. And this guy was a housebreaker. He had opened many locks in his life, and he tried it and tried it and tried it and literally his potential freedom was genuinely on the line. And he had to turn the thing back in and say, you couldn't do it and he couldn't imagine
有一次，他们向一个囚犯提供假释，条件是如果他能破解查勃锁。这个家伙是个入室盗窃犯。他一生中打开过许多锁，他试了又试，试了又试，字面意思是他潜在的自由确实悬于一线。他不得不把东西还回去并说，你做不到，而且他无法想象
that anyone could do it. And going forward, the names Brahma and Shub are basically interchangeable for perfect security. But only until the great lock controversy of 1851. In 1851, an American named AC Hobbs traveled to London for the Great Exhibition, the first international exhibition of manufactured products. Back in the States, Hobbs had made a name for himself as a sort of white hat security consultant. He'd go visit banks and say, hey, if I can break the lock on your safe, you want to buy one of mine, the banks would be like, yeah, sure, give it a shot. And he was selling locks like
任何人都能做到。展望未来，布拉马和查勃的名字基本上可以互换，代表绝对安全。但直到1851年的那场伟大的锁具争论。1851年，一个名叫AC·霍布斯的美国人前往伦敦参加第一届国际工业产品博览会——万国博览会。回到美国后，霍布斯作为一种白帽安全顾问为自己树立了名声。他会去拜访银行说，嘿，如果我能撬开你保险箱上的锁，你想买一个我的吗，银行会说，好吧，当然，试试看。而他一直在卖锁，卖得
crazy. Hobbs was a natural. And naturally, on day one of the exhibition, he publicly announced that he would pick the Chubb detector lock. The one that seizes up if you pick it incorrectly. Hobbs successfully picked the Chubb detector lock in front of a crowd. But the inventor, Jeremiah Chubb, wasn't convinced. He wanted to see Hobbs do it again. So another trial was set, this time in front of auditors and reporters.
疯狂。霍布斯是个天才。理所当然地，在展览的第一天，他公开宣布他将撬开查勃探测锁。那个如果你撬错就会卡住的锁。霍布斯在人群面前成功地撬开了查勃探测锁。但发明家杰里迈亚·查勃并不信服。他想看霍布斯再做一次。于是进行了另一次试验，这次是在审计员和记者面前。
And AC Hobbs opened the lock again. Take that Chubb. He actually opened the lock pretty quickly. A witness wrote that it took Hobbs about 25 minutes, and the way Hobbs did it was to actually use the lock against itself. He would pick it until he tripped the detector mechanism, causing the lock to seize up. That would give Hobbs information about what was going on inside, and then he would pick the lock in the opposite direction to reset the detector.
而AC·霍布斯再次打开了锁。拿去吧，查勃。他实际上相当快地打开了锁。一位目击者写道，霍布斯花了大约25分钟，霍布斯的方法是以其人之道还治其人之身。他会一直撬锁，直到他触发了探测机构，导致锁卡住。这会给霍布斯提供关于里面发生的事情的信息，然后他会向相反的方向撬锁以重置探测器。
He'd go back and forth firing and resetting the detector until the lock told him everything he needed to know about how to get it open. And then he closed it again and then he opened it again. This time in seven minutes. He had complete control over the chub lock. It has absolutely been opened. But the chub detector lock was really just a warm-up. The main event was the Brahma safety lock, the one with the challenge painted on it in gold lettering, which had been sitting in
他会来回触发并重置探测器，直到锁告诉他关于如何打开它的所有信息。然后他又把它关上，然后又把它打开。这次用了七分钟。他对查勃锁拥有完全的控制权。它绝对被打开了。但查勃探测锁真的只是热身。重头戏是布拉马安全锁，那个上面用金字塔涂着挑战的锁，它一直放在
Joseph Brahma's storefront window for 70 years, unbeaten, taunting lock pickers everywhere. AC Hobbs threw down the gauntlet. So a trial was conducted against the Brahma lock, they give him 30 days to conduct himself against it. Joseph Brahma had died by this point, and his sons were running his shop. They gave Hobbes a room above his store, and Hobbes got to work. He was allowed to set the lock up in a way
约瑟夫·布拉马店面的橱窗里70年，未被击败，嘲弄着各地的开锁者。AC·霍布斯抛出了战书。因此，针对布拉马锁进行了试验，他们给他30天的时间来对付它。约瑟夫·布拉马此时已经去世，他的儿子们在经营他的店铺。他们给霍布斯在店里上面留了一个房间，霍布斯开始工作了。他被允许以一种
that was easy to work on, and he could use all his own tools. Monitors would come check in on him periodically. He winds up bringing on this thing for about 52 hours over the course of 14 days and finally gets it open and the way that he gets it open is much more like sort of brute forcing it. He kind of designed a method of building a key for it It wasn't super elegant. It couldn't be really easily repeated against a brand new one and some of his methods could have been prevented with some slight alterations But still the Prama lock had been opened. When Hobbes opened that lock, I swear to you the world changed.
容易操作的方式设置锁，并且他可以使用他自己的所有工具。监视员会定期来看看他。他最终在这东西上花了大约52个小时，在14天的时间里，最后把它打开了，他打开它的方式更像是某种蛮力破解。他有点设计了一种为它制作钥匙的方法。它不是超级优雅。它不能针对全新的锁很容易地重复，并且他的一些方法可以通过一些微小的改动来预防。但尽管如此，布拉马锁还是被打开了。当霍布斯打开那锁时，我向你发誓，世界变了。
Overnight, the feeling of perfect security had evaporated, and we have never gotten it back. Locksmiths weren't able to convince the public that perfect security could be restored, but they did keep inventing new locks. One such locksmith was Linus Yale Jr. You've probably seen present day locks with the name Yale on them, that's because Yale's company was able to mass produce their locks in a scale that no one ever had. Their lock became the most common in the world. Yale's design, patented in 1851, the same year as the Great Lock
一夜之间，绝对安全的感觉蒸发了，而我们再也没有找回它。锁匠们没能说服公众绝对安全可以恢复，但他们确实一直在发明新的锁。其中一位锁匠是小林纳斯·耶鲁。你可能见过带有耶鲁名字的现代锁，那是因为耶鲁的公司能够以无人能及的规模大规模生产他们的锁。他们的锁成为了世界上最常见的锁。耶鲁的设计于1851年获得专利，与伟大的锁具争论
Controversy, was called the Pin and Tumblr Lock. It's the kind of lock you see everywhere. If you live in an apartment building, this is almost certainly the same style of lock as you have on your front door of your apartment building. It's the kind of lock that Lee Honeywell taught me how to pick. This is a design that's been really commercially successful because it's super cheap to make,
同年，被称为弹子锁。这是你在各处都能看到的锁。如果你住在公寓楼里，这几乎肯定和你的公寓楼前门上的锁是同一个风格的锁。这就是李·亨尼韦尔教我如何开锁的那种锁。这是一个在商业上取得巨大成功的的设计，因为制造起来超级便宜，
and works pretty well. The pin tumbler locks we have today are not too different from the pin tumbler locks manufactured a century ago. And the common pin tumbler lock is nowhere near as secure as the beast that was the Brahma Safety Lock, which took one of the greatest minds in locksmithing more than 50 hours to defeat. With about two hours of instruction and some practice, anyone even you can pick a simple door lock in a few minutes, and if you're feeling confident in your abilities, you can square off against other lockfickers.
而且运作得相当好。我们今天拥有的弹子锁与一个世纪前制造的弹子锁没有太大区别。而普通的弹子锁远不如布拉马安全锁那样安全，后者花了锁匠界最伟大的头脑之一50多个小时才被攻克。经过大约两个小时的指导和一些练习，任何人，甚至是你，都可以在几分钟内打开一把简单的门锁，如果你对自己的能力感到自信，你可以与其他开锁者一较高下。
And that's our man Skyler Town competing there at a match in New York City. He's also competed in arguably the World Cup of Locksport the Dutch Open. Competitive Locksport these days isn't so much about whether the locks can be beaten. The more about how fast you can beat them. And the locks used for competitions are often a lot more complicated than your average door lock. The lock on your door is so easily subverted. Just casually subverted, really, on most people's doors. With some skill in patience with attention wrench and lock pick set, you can get into almost anyone's house. But you don't even need that much.
那就是我们的斯凯勒·托恩在纽约市的一场比赛中竞争。他还在可以说是开锁运动世界杯的荷兰公开赛中竞争过。如今的竞技开锁与其说是关于锁能否被击败。不如说是关于你能以多快的速度击败它们。比赛中使用的锁通常比你的普通门锁复杂得多。你门上的锁很容易被破解。只需随意的破解，真的，在大多数人的门上。只要有一点技术和耐心，配上张力扳手和开锁器套装，你就能进入几乎任何人的家。但你甚至不需要那么多。
Just a few seconds with a crowbar or a brick through a window will do the job nicely. Our homes are incredibly porous. The locks in place now at banks and other high security venues are light years beyond what they had in the 1800s. But the average consumer grade locks didn't evolve nearly as much. It's not that we don't need locks, we do. We just don't need them to be impenetrable. What we're actually trusting is not the lock, what we're trusting is our community.
只需用撬棍几秒钟或者一块砖头砸碎窗户就能把活干得很好。我们的家极其脆弱。银行和其他高安保场所现在使用的锁比19世纪的锁要先进光年。但普通消费者级别的锁并没有进化那么多。并不是我们不需要锁，我们确实需要。我们只是不需要它们刀枪不入。我们真正信任的不是锁，我们信任的是我们的社区。
We're trusting this sort of social order. And what the lock is now, the lock is a social construct as much as it is a mechanical construct. And so in a post-perfect security world, most of the locks that we interact with every day don't inspire us to trust them, they inspire us to trust each other. And that's why a $15 lock from your local hardware store will probably suffice. 99% invisible was produced this week by Sam Greenspan, the Katie Mingle, Avery Troubleman and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 KALW San Francisco and produced at the offices of Arxite in architecture
我们信任这种社会秩序。而现在的锁，锁既是一种社会建构，也是一种机械建构。因此，在后绝对安全的世界里，我们每天与之互动的绝大多数锁并不会激发我们去信任它们，它们激发我们去信任彼此。这就是为什么你当地五金店15美元的锁可能就足够了。99%隐形本周由萨姆·格林斯潘制作，凯蒂·明格尔，埃弗里·特拉布曼和罗曼·马尔斯我本人。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心的建筑和室内设计公司Arxite的办公室制作。
and interiors firm in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. You can find the show and like the show on Facebook. We're all on Twitter, Tumblr, Instagram and Spotify, but you can unpick the lock that is 99% invisible at 99pi.org. Radio to PO. From PRX. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目并点赞。我们都在Twitter、Tumblr、Instagram和Spotify上，但你可以在99pi.org上解开99%隐形这把锁。来自PRX的Radio to PO。这个节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子来留下评论。